House Democrats want top immigration
officials from the Trump administration
to testify this week about the crisis at
the border the lawmakers want answers
about reports of dangerous and
unsanitary conditions and migrant
detention facilities then Tracy's at the
White House with more on this story Ben
good morning to you what can you tell us
about what's actually being done well
the president is promising more
transparency he even says he wants to
get journalists in to see these
facilities but there's also a bit of a
mixed message coming out of the
administration on the one hand they're
blaming Democrats for the conditions and
on the other the president is saying
these migrants are actually in better
shape in these facilities than where
they came from but a report from the New
York Times this weekend details
horrendous conditions at the Klint
border facility in Texas outbreaks of
scabies shingles and chickenpox
spreading among the hundreds of children
being held in cramped cells President
Trump called The Times report a hoax an
acting homeland security secretary Kevin
McLennan called the allegations
unsubstantiated because there's adequate
food and water because the facility is
cleaned every day because I know what
our standards are and I know they're
being followed even a report by his own
Department of Homeland Security's
inspector general described overcrowding
at detention facilities as dangerous and
a ticking time bomb we've been talking
about this we've been asking for help
I'm not denying that there are
challenging situations at the border
acting director of US Citizenship and
Immigration Services Ken Cuccinelli
claims that since Congress passed a 4.6
billion dollar humanitarian aid bill the
situation has improved we've gone from
about 2,500 children in facilities not
designed for them down to a fraction of
that Democrats who visited detention
facilities in Texas last week say the
conditions are still unacceptable they
are in a facility that is dehumanizing
now the administers the administration
says that it is disappointed that
Congress appears to have no plans to
address asylum laws before its August
recess they also say they are ready for
mass
and deportations of people who are here
in the country illegally but it's
unclear when those may start Tony
Ben Tracy Forrest Ben thank you very
much